this video was made possible by class
central.com
/ Pakman which gives you access to
thousands of online lectures from the
world's top universities check it out by
clicking the link under this video
medicine is full of pseudoscience to the
point where some people refer to
practices like reiki faith healing and
homeopathy as quack adem 'ok medicine
and on this episode of the pseudo
science mini-series i'm gonna focus in
on reiki which is an alternative
medicine that's akin to faith healing
with a dose of supposed Eastern
mysticism substituted for Christian
theology Reiki if you're not familiar
with it at its core is a ritual where a
practitioner will place their hands over
the clients body channeling so-called
universal energy into them and Reiki
users and practitioners believe that
illness is caused by a disruption or an
imbalance in a person's key or Qi that
being your vital energy or life force
and what Reiki seeks to do claims to do
is to bring balance where there was an
imbalance and therefore your health
improves these sessions can last between
30 and 90 minutes the clients are
typically fully clothed
usually laying down on a massage table
or a bed and the practitioner will move
their hands between 12 and 15 positions
on the clients body sometimes they will
leave the hands in each position
anywhere from two to five minutes until
they feel that the flow of energy has
stopped the clients are told that they
might feel heat or tingling as that
energy flows there are lots of different
offshoots of Reiki all followed the same
basic tenets with slight variations for
example most practitioners will not make
physical contact with the client during
the ritual but there are some that will
depending on the school of Reiki that
they subscribe to and depending on the
so called level of mastery it's also
possible for the practitioner to do
Reiki from a distance which is really
convenient for everybody right despite
claims by some that Reiki is an ancient
healing method it was actually found
in the early 20th century by the
Buddhist monk Macau Tsui in the 20s
Sooey fasted and meditated for 21 days
on Mount Kurama in Japan and when he
emerged from this seclusion he claimed
that he received a revelation of an
ancient Tibetan practice which we now
know as Reiki it's been claimed that
asou a was a Christian priest and had a
doctorate in theology none of that's
true and was actually made up by Reiki
practitioners during the 20th century in
order to ingratiate themselves with
American Christians and in reality who
suya was a missionary of a Shintoism
related religion
so again advocates claim that the
practice is ancient and that use of
Reiki energy has been around for at
least a thousand years and according to
Reiki org quote some feel it has been
around since the beginning of time there
is no proof that who Suey rediscovered
anything ancient he actually created
Reiki by borrowing bits and pieces from
Japanese and Buddhist traditions and
then rebranded them as something new
right now no special background or
credentials are needed to become a Reiki
practitioner you need only an atonement
from a master and training for the basic
levels of attunement can take as little
as one to two days very efficient but
years of training are needed to reach
these supposed highest levels no
licensing is required and interestingly
surprising to some people interest in
Reiki is quite large and it keeps
growing according to a CDC survey in
2006 1.2 million adults and a hundred
and sixty one thousand kids in the US
received one or more energy healing
sessions like Reiki and Reiki education
is offered across the country at roughly
eight hundred hospitals and more than 60
hospitals explicitly offer Reiki to the
patients themselves very often the
hospitals end up offering Reiki to the
patients not because the hospital
necessarily believes that Reiki works or
because there's definitive science
behind it but because it's the patient
that demand reiki there was a 2008 study
of hospitals that utilize touch healing
practices such as Reiki which found that
84% sighted patient demand as the
primary reason for offering these
services the cleveland clinic which is a
non-profit academic Medical Center in
Cleveland Ohio is one such hospital they
advertise Reiki for the treatment of
cancer chronic pain infertility
digestive problems parkinson's disease
at the University of Arizona Medical
Center they offer cancer patients all
sorts of quack Adamic treatments
including Reiki and they tell the
patients that those treatments can boost
your immune system and complement
conventional chemotherapy the benefits
are not well enumerated and it's unclear
how Reiki could actually help with any
of those conditions instead of offering
it as a replacement for actual treatment
practitioners of Reiki and the hospitals
and the medical facilities that offer it
will typically recommend integrating
Reiki into whatever treatment plan the
patient is already undergoing and to
provide a veneer of scientific
legitimacy Reiki defenders talk about
something called quantum entanglement
which describes a phenomenon in quantum
physics when pairs of group or groups of
particles act upon each other and become
an entangled system and defenders of
Reiki used this as a pretext to claim
that Reiki practitioners can affect
others on a quantum scale it's tough to
really pin them down but ultimately the
scientific justification boils down to
Reiki works because quantum physics and
that's more or less the beginning and
end of the argument there is a 2011
paper which investigated the difference
between treatment by a certified Reiki
practitioner no intervention and a
placebo practitioner right someone who
was not trained in Reiki both the quote
real Reiki and the fake Reiki performed
better than the no intervention group
but the real and fake Reiki performed
exactly the same so to put it simply in
that study Rey keys effects were the
placebo effect not uncommon in
pseudoscience in 2008 the Journal of
alternative and complementary medicine
published a randomized controlled trial
of Rey keys effects on fibromyalgia pain
and it stated plainly that quote neither
reiki nor touch improved the symptoms of
fibromyalgia in 2008 in the
international journal of clinical
practices published a review entitled
effects of reiki in clinical practice a
systematic review of randomized clinical
trials and came to the following
conclusion quote the evidence is
insufficient to suggest that reiki is an
effective treatment for any condition
therefore the value of reiki remains
unproven the comprehensive literature
reviews are unable to say with precision
whether or not reiki is able to work
hypothetically largely because the
studies available for reviews are almost
entirely bad science the few good
experiments that exist like the ones i
cited are vastly outweighed by the
number of studies that are set up
specifically to prove that reiki is real
although the science behind reiki is
thin interest in reiki as I mentioned
keeps growing Ricky's influence has
actually grown so large that in 2009 the
Catholic Church felt the need to release
official doctrine regarding the
acceptability of Reiki for Catholics and
Catholic hospitals and the reason for
doing this as far as they said was
because of a strong demand from clergy
and Catholics more generally for Reiki
and the report was unequivocal saying
quote Reiki therapy is not compatible
with either Christian teaching or
scientific evidence it would be
inappropriate for Catholic institutions
to promote or to provide support for
Reiki therapy a Catholic who puts his or
her trust in Reiki would be operating in
the realm of superstition this is from
an institution the Catholic Church it
still offers classes at the Vatican on
how to perform exorcisms ultimately when
it comes to pseudo scientific medical
treatments like Reiki the question of
harm is an important one sessions of
Reiki aren't exactly cheap they can
range
forty to $300 each but for all its
faults and unscientific substantiation
it doesn't cause side-effects from its
use ray keys use and hospitals can also
be humanizing for people who are living
in these sterile and dehumanizing
conditions if you're stuck in a hospital
for cancer treatments having someone
come to your bed and focus on your rest
and relaxation can be very valuable
however maybe a therapy dog would
provide many of the same benefits at no
or little cost and brighten the day of
people truly suffering without
compromising them completely - an
unsubstantiated benefits if human
interaction and care or patients truly
are seeking when they ask for treatments
like Reiki hospitals have a duty to
provide services that work better than
the placebo effect demonstrably so Reiki
might make the patient feel better but
services like providing massage have
been shown to increase the well-being of
people beyond just the placebo effect
when a massage is given with a similar
level of empathy and care and dedication
the physical and psychological benefits
are very very real hospitals can't
justify ineffective treatments like
Reiki just because there's a placebo
effect associated with it doesn't make
sense for research dollars to continue
to be invested in the study of Reiki
those dollars instead should be going
into the research for diseases that
Reiki claims to help but isn't actually
demonstrated to help break EES benefits
are real to some people through the
placebo effect and may have helped
someone you know while they have been
battling a disease but Reiki is
pseudoscience after all if Reiki really
is as wondrous as its proponents claims
shouldn't its effects on humans be
quantifiable and credibly provable so
Reiki is totally pseudo scientific but
if you want to delve into disciplines
that are actually founded on real
evidence and academic research check out
class - central.com / Packman or click
the link underneath this video as you
might know by now class central lets you
take entire college courses
online from top universities including
Harvard and other Ivy League schools MIT
Stanford Berkeley and whether you're
interested in science politics
philosophy psychology there are tens of
thousands of courses to choose from on
almost any topic imaginable many of them
are completely free check it out for
yourself click the link in the
description search for a class on a
topic that fascinates you that is class
- central.com /p a que ma n